the real fight between Mark Zuckerberg
and Elon Musk is happening online
Twitter now threatening to sue meta over
its brand new quote Twitter killer app
called threats Zuckerberg boasting that
30 million people joined in just the
first day including Big Time celebs like
Oprah and Kim Kardashian here's the Zuck
we are launching threads in open and
friendly public space for conversations
I am looking forward to the fun journey
ahead to turn this into the the kind of
big and friendly community that I think
we all want to see in the world
Elon Musk is clapping back same quote
comp is fine cheating is not
um don't come to you yeah
you just say whatever
okay uh there was a cease and desist
letter that was sent today to Mark
Zuckerberg from uh Elon musk's people
basically saying that uh meta through
threads has engaged in systematic
willful and unlawful misappropriation of
Trade Secrets now what's interesting
about this is that apparently everything
that's happened in this Lane is you have
Instagram that copied stories from
Snapchat and then Instagram created
reels which was a mimic of tick tock and
now Tick Tock has stories and they all
copy and take from each other but at
this point uh Elon Musk is saying you
know those people that I fired you're
hiring them and you were literally
copying and taking some of the trade
secrets and your threads is nothing more
than Twitter with a new name
Katie what do you make of that I mean I
so I don't have an Instagram account so
I can't get a threads account which I
think is silly and they should let
people you could get more signups if
that's not one of the restrictions it
does have a different word count
right but it doesn't have
um hashtags which is the main search
engine for Twitter and that seems like
something that would be really similar
if this was true that it was just a
carbon copy well there are a lot of
people who left Twitter when Elon Musk
took over who are now working as
Engineers for this new thread service
for Zuckerberg
um I bet a lot of people in Silicon
Valley would argue that Zuck tends to
take things that they don't think are
his he was accused of stealing Facebook
they caught that out in the courts he
did not end up being guilty of doing
that but in terms of the technology you
know these sites come and go like
Myspace was a thing then Facebook came
along and and it's so interesting to
watch how fast tech moves and how
quickly people's attention span dies out
and they move on to the next thing or
not you know if you've built an audience
on Twitter of millions of followers you
don't necessarily want to go start over
on threads you might see it as another
way to reach more people but at some
point there are lots of different
platforms to choose from to get your
message out and it might become like too
saturated with places to say the same
thing essentially Greg do you think that
this will impact whatever the fate of
the lawsuit is we'll see how that plays
out but Twitter doing some hard thinking
about the changes to the app that
they've made well first off I had to
share a floor with Myspace when when we
bought them on the 13th floor they were
horrible people do you know that they
put Post-it notes on their food in the
fridge please don't eat this so we were
at red eye at the time we purposely ate
stuff of course and we would smoke
cigarettes in their office just so it's
in the fridge that's why they had the
post
the thing is okay so
what Twitter right so I'm assuming that
this is all something else that there
this is a race for the AI uh interface
right and once you get the artificial
intelligence interface all the apps go
away so you don't need Amazon or PayPal
or Twitter or YouTube It's one
relationship it's one relationship with
this your little best friend and he's
going to predict everything that you
need in life and you're never going to
use your brain it's going to be amazing
it's going to handle language and
Mathematics and and directions in case
you're lost and I think that's what's
happening is you're seeing two of the
richest people going in that direction
and this is where I can link it to why
wokism failed oh thank God
if everything is based on prediction
especially language this is why the
whole pronoun thing fell apart because
it's like if you look at a man and he
says I'm a she it's like the that it
doesn't work and so that just imploded
and fell apart that's my my theory
anyway is why wokeism because it doesn't
follow a predictive pattern
quote me on that if you like
do you remember all your Math teachers
saying it's not like you're always going
to have a calculator with you yes well
yeah who's laughing now probably not
them I I just want to know why you would
want threads and not Instagram I mean
Instagram is at least fun yeah but you
still have Instagram you just also I
don't know why you personally oh me yeah
so I
I started working here because Sean
Hannity told me that I would miss out on
all the fun and knowing what's going on
and I find it to be the greatest news
source but more difficult now if I had
social media like that I would spend 28
hours a day looking at everyone's old
pictures being like Oh you know what's
that guy doing that I went on one date
with in 20 you know typically it's not
healthy yeah
that's fine I can take 24 hours in a day
Jessica that's why it made my point more
really yeah oh okay bye hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else